my biggest thing is you know coming here
I was just excited for a fresh start
I came here as 20 I was 22 and I got
traded I'm only 23 now but
um when I came here it was like it's
just a fresh beginning for me
um and I credit a lot of the reason that
I've been able to succeed to my family
and uh making that transition seamless
for me top to bottom along with my
agents just making that very easy taking
care of everything getting everything
here just making it be as stress-free as
possible for me to get here and just
play basketball and that's all I want to
do at the end of the day there's so many
people here for me to thank but I
wouldn't
I'd be wrong to not start with my mom
you know she I don't know a lot of
people don't know this my mom missed my
first ever game my freshman year of
college because the plane didn't take
off to get to Lubbock to go to watch
Texas Tech so before my freshman year my
mom had never missed a game of mine so
my mom has
been my everything for me to get here
um you know I can't even put into words
to explain everything but I'm just
really appreciative of you mom
um because of you know all the stuff of
us growing up and
pushing me to you know
be where I am today and um
making sure I could get every trip
making sure my teammates made it to
every trip um
it just means a lot to me so I love you
and I'm really appreciative of
you so thank you Mom I love you
[Applause]
uh and then my pops uh y'all know he's
the one who put the ball in my hand I
actually just told this story the other
day on a podcast but like girls my dad
coached the girls middle school team
when I was born and I see I meet these
girls all the time like they're like oh
I held you when you were a baby I don't
have no room I don't remember it at all
but uh they always say like when I was
barely old enough to like crawl my dad
would make sure that like one half of
the Court was reserved for me and one
half for his team so they were probably
a great half court basketball team but
probably not the best getting up and
down but uh you know my dad has always
pushed me he's my biggest fan as you
guys can see that I mean this guy's
wearing a Jersey to the press conference
but uh man I'm really appreciative of
you Pops and uh your love and uh you
know you've always been my biggest fan
pushed me to you know get here push me
to want to be better and
um you know you the biggest thing you
told me is when this becomes a job and
not a game that you don't want me to do
anymore and uh obviously there's a deal
here but this is still just fun for me
it's basketball
um and it just reminds me of you know
being two three four years old and
having a ball in my hand so you know I
love you too I really appreciate you